ne quittez pas rouge pam a mis à l'eau
alexandre alexandre urwicz si vous dînez
avec vous ce soir à je ne sais je
voudrais jamais vous dire que je vous ai
attendu au soir de 8h à 10h chez harris
cela vous ferait de la peine je le sais
vous êtes trop sensible je ne peux pas
vous dire non plus que je suis au
courant de votre sortie avec cette
fausse blonde vous vous trouviez si
vulgaire cela vous diminuerait à mon
endroit
vous avez trop de fierté
oh bien sûr je peux pas vous dire non
plus votre démarche
cette façon de dire je roule ou vos
médard me mais le coeur en joie que
votre aire de conquérant votre absence
de répartie mais entendu que vous avez
sur toute chose la tranquillité et le
vide qui émane de vaud mais merde à
chaque instant mais si je ne peux pas
vous dire non plus que vous êtes samus
ans et pour toutes les femmes derrière
votre haute stature et votre présence
musclée une toute petite poupée que nous
aimons sortir ceux ci après une rude
journée de labeur ou tout simplement par
désoeuvrement la verrerie
couperet alexandre alexandrie
je sais tout à présent c'est ainsi que
je vous ai pas propos j'ai vu le
cabriolet qui vous fait tellement envie
je crois avoir toutes les facilités pour
vous l'offre pour pour l'obtenir vous
viendrez dîner avec moi ce soir
merci le numéro que vous avez demandé
n'est pas attribué lmnp regrettons de ne
pas pouvoir donner suite à votre appel